[Music]
[Applause]
i talk about this every single year and
it's the quarterback roller coaster ride
it feels like every quarterback gets one
week and then you're going oh
okay matt corral
and that'll be sam howe malik willis
well it's desmond ritter week not
officially but that's what happens when
it comes to these quarterbacks as we get
ready for the draft there's going to be
somebody moving up
and it'll be somebody moving down dan
arlovsky knows that quite well the espn
football analyst you can see him monday
through friday at 4 eastern on nfl live
he joins us on the program how are you
celebrating desmond ritter week the
cincinnati quarterback there dan
well uh not much celebration you know
because it's 40 degrees and raining in
connecticut right now so there's nothing
to celebrate it you know the weather is
just so bad um
here's my here's my thought i think
you're accurate with that whole the
roller coaster per the week thing
so
you know i probably call dan i don't
know a handful of desmond ritter games
you know i'm calling college football
for espn i think when you sit down and
you have conversations with him you get
really impressed i mean that is the
strength of his
you sit down you see his maturity he's a
four-year starter he's got a young child
so you know he's not living the
quote-unquote college life he's he's
very mature and you sit there and you go
that's that's the guy that you want uh
you know kind of the representation
certainly at that position
of your organization um
i think desmond rudder is a good player
i really do i think he's a you know an
alex smith ryan tannehill type of
quarterback that
mechanically very sound
sneakily good athlete is going to make
the right throw at the right time versus
the right coverage you got good people
around him gonna be a good player
i just don't believe that there are
anything physically trait wise physical
trait wise that you sit there and go
that's a guy that we can't pass on like
we're gonna regret passing on him
specifically in the first round so while
i think he's a good player i love the
kid i don't think there's any
quarterback in this draft class that has
a physical talent outside of malik
willis that says man we might regret
passing on him
would the lions go all in at two on
malik willis
i don't think you should i really don't
i don't think they will i don't think
it's that time yet for them i still
believe that they are trying to build it
the right way which they've never done
really
and
you know i don't malik willis while he's
got some of those first-round traits you
know the athleticism the big arm the
escapability the wow throws the jaw
dropping i can't coach that into a guy
he's also a guy that is going to be
under six foot one
and i understand that the position is
different nowadays than in the past
and you could sit here and say well
kyler went one and baker met went one
and some
the difference is that those guys you
one i could point out
there's still some question marks about
them play-wise those those young the
smaller guys and russell wilson and drew
brees they're maniacal about their craft
maniacal so all the other aspects of
their games were elevated i can't sit
here and tell you that malik willis is
or is not i don't know
um and i don't think the lions are
um in the situation or position in the
process of what they're trying to do
under brad holmes and dan campbell to
sit there and go all right let's get the
quarterback now
the eagles in saints trade
i don't know what it signified to you
but it certainly felt like
philadelphia is going to give jalen
hurts one more year
and then if they want to go into the
quarterback market they'll have a little
extra ammo to do that or am i reading
too much into
what we what we saw with that trade
earlier this week
no i think for philadelphia it's just in
case
you know i i think that
with their because if they were really
do i believe that they're sold on jalen
hurts no they're sold enough to give him
this season and they've got a good
football team
um if they weren't sold on him at least
potentially being that guy they got
three ones this year they could have
shipped out to seattle and given seattle
more than denver gave them so if that
was something that they were like nope
not gonna happen they would have made
the move this year i think that they are
interested in him being the guy for the
future and that's why they are going
about their business this off season the
way they are
but they have that extra pick next year
is it just in case it doesn't work out i
still think that jalen hurts is going to
lead them to the division title this
year
if they get a receiver in this draft
over the next three weeks they got to
get a receiver in one of those first
round picks to go with devante smith
um do you think they'll beat the cowboys
in the east
yeah i think the cowboys have a rude
awakening coming two-fold i think that
offensive line got old very quickly and
sub-par very quickly um i don't know
tyron smith how many games he's got left
in him there's question marks at left
tackle left guard center and right
tackle
zach martin's the only kind of sure
thing we know also their schedule is
brutal i mean i could point to six
remember they were 6-0 last year in
within the division and i believe six
and
five outside of the division
and their outside of division opponents
are
off the top of my head dan i think it's
like tampa bay the rams
buffalo
um
uh minnesota like they got they got some
teams that are going to be good football
teams that they have to play green bay
and
uh green bay yeah i think san francisco
might be in there as well so
um i think that philadelphia if jalen
hurts takes another step like all we've
seen him do since his freshman year at
alabama
and they hit on a receiver in the first
round i think they got a good chance to
win that division we got an in-house bet
uh paulie my producer says quarterback's
going to be taken in the first within
the first 13 picks
yeah um
gosh this reminds me of like that 2012
draft where
you know i don't want to be
disrespectful to these guys but if i
remember 12 was like
ponder went early gabbert went early uh
locker went early and and they they
weren't really
worthy of those early picks um
yeah i think
if there was one team that i would sit
here and say yeah i feel that that could
be the case it would be atlanta i can i
can make the case that atlanta should
full rebuild dead cap space all that i
think that if you're gonna do it it has
to be malik willis i think willis and
i've talked about that a little bit
already but i think there's got to be
two things in place
if you're going to be the team that
drafts malik willis number one you have
to have a starter
that is ready and capable to go play
malik willis does not have traits yet
that allow him to survive you know his
offense was very
tempo pushed the ball downfield tempo
pushed the ball down so he's got to grow
and develop i don't use the phrase ready
or not ready i think that's dumb
um
and then you gotta have a coach that
doesn't need to win
and have the pressure of putting the
young player on there that's why i get a
little hesitant with carolina because i
i think that matt rules just you would
anticipate he's got to win some games
and show some promise this year and i
don't want the pressure for that so
will will the guy go in the top 13 i
would anticipate that to be the case
yeah
yeah it's just it's strange how these
gm's that you know they probably say be
patient going to be patient and then the
draft happens and then they're not
patient you know yeah you got jerry
jones wanting to draft johnny manziel
it's like let's go get him then you're
like no no no no let's let's show some
restraint here but that happens every
single year
and i yeah and the ironic thing is more
often than not
it's teams that don't necessarily
know what the answer is if they don't
panic and that's crazy to think
i don't think that there's many teams in
the first round there that have that
frames of mindset though i don't think
carolina can get i think carolina would
be the one team that i could see her and
say they might get into panic mode i
don't believe atlanta will get into
panic mode i don't believe pittsburgh
will get into panic mode carolina could
be the one team that might sit there and
go we're hearing rumblings that this
this team might take them if we don't
get him here that's when you get into
those problems where you overdraft a
player
why is there this fascination with baker
mayfield with the media
i think he brings it on himself a little
bit right you know he's got the
personality that is uh you know very you
know abrasive um i think that
um it goes back to the oklahoma days and
he was the walk-on and then at the
oklahoma days and he's the heisman
trophy
you know winner and he plants the flag
against ohio state in in a you know big
time national game and the
the antics against kansas on this island
so i think there was a little bit of
that
um immaturity so to speak in college
that brought it upon himself at a
program like oklahoma and then you know
he goes to
cleveland the surprise pick the picture
represents
replicating brett favre and you know
then he has some instant success he
breaks peyton manning breaks russell
wilson's records and he's just very
outspoken and very confident and um you
know when you're allowed as a
quarterback your play has to be louder
and if it's not
you are going to get absolutely
attacked by the media and i think that's
probably where we're sitting with baker
mayfield he's dan orlovsky espn football
analyst you can see him on nfl live
every weekday afternoon 4 eastern on
espn
i don't know how the
i know you guys spent a lot of money at
espn on joe buck and troy aikman but the
clock behind you has not moved since
we've been talking to one another you're
in the you're in the makeup room and
usually you got to keep an eye on the
clock
so you get down to the studio on time
dan i'm i'm worried about you know some
penny pinching going on at the
mothership
well
hopefully that's not the case um
uh yeah you know you know espn and jimmy
pataro you know obviously joe buck and
troy i i love game analysts i think troy
is the best in the game so
um you know and i've heard great things
about him i'm hoping he sends me some of
his new beer um but yeah i you know what
i'm not a watch guy dan so if i need to
tell the time i just peek at the phone
um i've never missed a segment don't
plan on it i've never been late to a
segment all those sports centers as you
know sportscenter producers run people
down here being like dan we need you i'm
like guys i'm on in seven minutes i got
it so i'm i'm hoping the penny pinching
isn't is into reality but you know i
still have nightmares i had one last
night that i showed up for sportscenter
late
it's still really after 18 years of
doing it
well you know your life is down to
minutes
and when you think about it it's down to
the second when you're on the air you
have 28 seconds for this you have uh 52
seconds it's always you got to be
thinking of the clock constantly so when
my wife says what time is it
then i'll say it's a 10 37. and then
yeah she'll go okay you could have said
10 30. i said no honest 10 37
because i was always so when i see that
i'm always looking at a clock making
sure
is it moved ahead so you'll be on time
and then that one hasn't moved yet so
that was it just a little bit
i'm like that football trained me to be
like that though you know like i think
tardiness is the most disrespectful and
one of the most disrespectful things in
the world so you know if it's if it's 10
30 like i'm with i'm with you on that
when my wife asks me the time what time
do you have to be there it's like hey we
gotta be there at 10 30. so we got to
leave at 10 10. well we live five
minutes away we have to be there at 10
30.
uh before i let you go
more impressive that tiger is teeing it
up at augusta or alex smith came back
from what he came back from to
actually play i think he was five and
one as a starter there coming back from
those surgeries here
what a question
um
i probably lean a little bit more
towards tiger because the age uh because
of all the other injuries attached to
his body nobody's chasing him on the
golf course i mean they're chasing him
on the leaderboard but figuratively
but he's he's doing it at almost a 50
year old as well you know i mean alex i
think what alex accomplished was
absolutely incredible but at 15 more
years attached to his life to do that i
think is on top of all those other
surgeries i just find it remarkable man
great to talk to you get the clock fixed
if you can
i'll see what i can do let you know by
the end of the summer if i can get that
done okay
that's dan arlovsky from the mothership
uh he's with laura rutledge marcus
spears meena kimes that's uh every day
afternoon 4 eastern